i've seen every stone's concert that has
come through
la any one not everyone but you know
they start i'm from toronto canada and
they combo the el mccombo is an album do
you know the album i think so yeah no
you don't
they would play the elma combo to work
out their show when they went on the
road it's just amazing it was really sad
at the beginning at the beginning of
that concert when they they said there
it's it's all too did we there right
from the beginning
you're talking too fast i can't keep one
i know i have a crazy accent
did you it was uh he dedicated the show
to their drummer who had passed oh yeah
yeah yeah am i hard to understand for
you
a little bit yeah you talk so fast i do
i'm going to start talking slower i want
to play just the moment that just this
is courtney on agt just you know what
your problem is dad what your problem is
you don't finish a thought like you're
hard for me to understand as well
because you don't finish a thought
you'll have a sentence and then you'll
end your sentence and start a new one
before the last word of your last
sentence was even spoken i don't
understand what you just said to be do
you understand what i'm saying he just
jumps from no no one understands
somebody's nodding yes caroline's not in
this okay let's play this watch this
this is one of the biggest surprises
i've ever had
we need sound
sound is a big there we go there we go
look out look at you look at simon look
at your design what are you thinking
are you watching
we're waiting we're waiting
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't want to pay for it i just want
to watch it so that's that that's
absolutely amazing it is absolutely
amazing now here's what's amazing we
just played that in here and i watched
you go oh god what what are you thinking
when you see that i hate listening back
to myself i hate it
you're a recording artist yeah i know
but i just don't like listening back to
myself i don't know why when you listen
to that do you think it's not good no i
just
a cringe i don't know why like whenever
i listen back to anything
that i do oh that sounds like whenever i
listen back to something that um
i do it just makes me feel weird even
now or looking back on old stuff no even
now
really yeah so but when you're in a
studio and you take and they do a take
of whatever you're going to record don't
you have to listen to it back
yeah but it's like i don't know how many
songs have you recorded since that day
oh absolutely long
no you can't even count it goes in loads
not numbers in weight
load is not a weight a load is a number
oh that's how they talk in northeast
okay in the northeast of england where
are you from you're from are you from
you're not from leeds
you don't like the pillow no it's not
cool what city are you from we're
throwing it just through the pillow
yeah you know that was a pillow given to
me by my grandmother who said in as long
as that pillow stays on your couch
you'll have good luck
oh and what did you just do with my
grandmother's pillow i'm sorry it wasn't
comfortable
what did you do with my grandmother's
pillow where did you put it on the floor
and now there's no more good luck for me
and
[Laughter]
i forgot what i was going to say it
doesn't matter
[Music]